nouvelle édition du 7 8 politique est
spécial municipal 2020 merci de nous
rejoindre sur tv 78 aujourd'hui je
reçois patrick gtr bonsoir bonsoir ce
plateau vous êtes tête de liste
remettons plaisir en marche candidat
donc sur cette ville de plaisir
avant de débuter cet entretien vous
m'avez demandé à pouvoir faire un mot
une pensée notamment pour les soldats
disparus
oui merci de m'accorder cela je voulais
élevé un petit peu les choses
et avant de discuter de nos enjeux
locaux nous rappeler qu'il y à des
personnes dans le monde et en france en
particulier qui donnent leur vie pour
les autres qui donnent leur vie pour que
nous puissions ce soir débattre
justement de notre avenir qu'ils soient
locales ou nationales donc je voulais
avoir ensemble une petite pensée
fraternelle pour ses treize soldats qui
ont été des cds pour leur famille et
également pour leurs frères d'armes
revenons à cette campagne et débutons
cet entretien par parler de votre
parcours vous étiez présent en 2014 sur
la liste de joséphine coleman berger
vous avez même durant ce mandat était
son adjoint aux finances pardon et ce
n'est qu'en septembre 2019 2019 que vous
avez décidé de de prendre vos distances
de passer dans l'opposition pourquoi ce
choix et pourquoi si tard alors
effectivement j'avais été nommé par joël
regnault le maire précédent en charge
des finances et de la commande publique
et puis avec
madame coleman ce berger nous avons
poursuivi ensemble sur un certain nombre
de choses sur lesquelles nous étions
d'accord en début de mandat avec une
feuille de route que nous avions défini
ensemble et puis qui petit à petit s'est
avéré un grand écart avec beaucoup de
différences de point de vue de gestion
d'orientation qui ont fait que quasiment
un tiers de la liste est sorti plusieurs
reprises pendant trois ans que nous nous
sommes posé des questions à plusieurs
tout au long de ce parcours et puis
quand on est adjoint quand on voit la
difficulté face aux dotations face aux
finances qu'on va le plus loin possible
dans le mandat que vous confient les
plaisirs war au delà de celui que vous
confie le maire et on ne lâche pas
forcément les choses comme ça mais quand
on est vraiment en désaccord on se doit
de bouger mais quitte à avoir des
désaccords profonds vous n'avez pas
pensé à partir plus tôt à quitter cette
majorité plutôt je reviens juste sur les
mots que vous avez au moment de ce
conseil on a vu quelques images du
conseil du mois de septembre
vous avez eu des mots assez durs un
désaccord sur la gestion les
orientations le mode de fonctionnement
mise en place par la mer elle a mis la
ville en panne
oui absolument c'est notre diagnostic
beaucoup de choses qui devaient être
faites n'ont pas été faites on a laissé
partir nos médecins
on a laissé se dégrader les transports
en commun les bus que ce soit les
fréquences et les circuits de bus on a
abandonné tous les combats qu'on devait
mener sur les pistes cyclables sur
l'emploi sur le social
et toutes ces dérives là aujourd'hui
nous sommes plusieurs à ne plus être
d'accord je ne suis plus d'accord et
donc à un moment donné vous arriverez en
septembre 2019 pour faire sourire à
gagner du temps mais la gagner beaucoup
de temps on en avait discuté au
printemps derrière on en a discuté avant
l'été et puis en septembre on a fait un
constat de désaccord
il ya un moment donné vous devez bouger
vous essayez de changer les choses de
l'intérieur vous n'y arrivais plus vous
devez sortir pour l'échangé de
l'extérieur mais ça veut dire que ce
bilan
vous ne l'assumé pas pendant cette
campagne s'est joué à l'ac milan de
joséphine coleman berger même si vous
avez fait partie de la majorité
une partie du bilan nous l'assumons on
ne jette pas tout il ya des choses sur
lesquelles nous étions d'accord des
choses qui ont été très bien fait pour
la ville notamment la négociation des
emprunts toxiques qui a permis de sauver
les finances de la ville
serra la ville de ces emprunts
absolument un certain nombre de combat
qu'on a mené ensemble sur le sport sur
l'école sur la culture mais beaucoup de
dérives entre temps sur la gestion sur
les frais qui s'envolent depuis trois
ans notamment des frais de personnel sur
un mal être au niveau des agents
proximité de l'animation particulier
hélas non nous ne sommes plus d'accord
aujourd'hui vous siéger dans
l'opposition avec d'autres élus qui ont
aussi a quitté le groupe majoritaire
vous vous siégez avec le groupe de la
république en marche aujourd'hui c'est
bien ça la république en marche et non
inscrits je préfère préciser gens qui
venaient de la membre adhérent de la
république en marche je suis
personnellement sympathisants de la
république en marche et également de lui
des ide ailleurs par ailleurs et nous
avons rejoint effectivement le groupe de
bernard ans à régis mortier et marc gêné
ce ton qui nous apparaissait comme un
groupe à la fois constructif tout au
long du mandat mais aussi propre à nous
amener demain à constituer une réunion
liste de majorité plurielle
après les élections ils sont présents
sur votre liste ils sont présents sur
cette liste certains d'entre eux seront
présents sur la liste je pense notamment
à bernard ansart oui président
socialiste aujourd'hui république en
marche est ce que vous allez présenter
une liste soutenue investi par la
république en marche est ce que les
estomacs de vous avez fait des démarches
dans ce sens nos constituants surtout
une liste plurielle comme je le disais
avec des gens de gauche des gens de
droite des gens non d'inscrits des
personnes qui viennent de l'écologie
beaucoup viennent du monde associatif
moi même qui me suis beaucoup pas
engagée dans le handicap et il se peut
qu effectivement durant notre parcours
nous ayons le soutien dans marche pour
poursuivre au delà de la ville surtout
parce qu'il ya des enjeux politiques
majeurs territoriaux majeur au niveau de
saint quentin et c'est à ce moment là
aussi qu'il faudra aborder ces enjeux
avec une politique un petit peu plus
globale
donc c'est important d'avoir ces deux
approches ça vous parler de ces gens est
en jeu sur saint quentin en yvelines sur
votre programme
la jeunesse par exemple certains axes de
votre programme l'emploi sport éducation
sont les demandes principales que vous
diagnostiquez pour cette jeune il ya
plus que ça le premier diagnostic que
nous avons posée c'est le monde écoute
et donc nous allons travailler
beaucoup plus étroitement avec une
politique de proximité dans les
quartiers avec la jeunesse avec les
associations avec un certain nombre
d'outils de consultations régulières des
plaisirs roi qui ne sont pas utilisés
aujourd'hui
le deuxième axe sur lequel nous
travaillons c'est tout ce qui concerne
la nature dans la ville l'environnement
les pistes cyclables sur lesquels nous
nous engageons à réaliser effectivement
un certain nombre de dizaines de
kilomètres dans notre ville sur le
prochain mandat parce que c'est
important sur l'animation des quartiers
aussi sur lequel nous allons travailler
et puis parce que pour travailler en
proximité faut que les agents se sont
bien là il ya quelque chose à faire en
termes de politique et ça devient urgent
sur l'emploi est ce que le bilan que
vous dressez est aussi en tout cas votre
appréciation négatif sur l'emploi sur la
politique de l'emploi parce que on
parlait de saint-quentin-en-yvelines ya
des choses qui sont faites au niveau de
50 ans une guinée qui bénéficie à
plaisir qu'il ya aux gens qui fait
aujourd'hui partie de cette
agglomération
on va pas encore assez loin il ya
beaucoup de choses qui sont écrites qui
sont dites pas encore qui sont faites
donc en termes de création d'activité
par exemple de création d'entreprise on
peut aller beaucoup plus loin
je crois beaucoup comme un certain
nombre numérique mais aussi à l'économie
verte à l'économie circulaire et là il
ya beaucoup de choses à faire sur la
zone de ste apolline et enfin troisième
axe nos commerçants les commerces de
proximité et notre artisanat et là ça a
été grandement oubliés avec des exemples
particuliers mettent le marché de noël
au château alors que notre marché a
besoin de soutien c'est une ineptie
quand nous serons passés nous allons
nous empresser de soutenir notre marché
de soutenir nos commerçants de proximité
et bien sûr de remettre le marché de
noël au beau monde
c'est le bilan que vous dressez sur la
ville de plaisir néanmoins durant ce
mandat la priorité aussi était de
s'intégrer à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'arrivée au sein de cette agglomération
hélas et s'est plutôt bien passé pour la
ville de plaisir je serai un petit peu
mitigé sur ce constat nous sommes
constructifs de part et d'autre c'est
pas encore optimale il faut apprendre à
travailler ensemble il faut apprendre à
trouver surtout des effets de
mutualisation des effets de levier
nous en sommes qu au début nous n'avons
pas trouvé les économies que nous
devrions trouver sur un certain nombre
de budget sur les médias
avec sur l'emploi sur le développement
économique sur les déchets aussi etc
je pense que les bases sont posées
maintenant il va falloir trouver une
direction différente
et puis surtout accélérer accélérer l'un
des dossiers qui sera important durant
cette campagne c'est aussi la gestion
quelquefois des détentions des
difficultés au sein de la ville et je
pense au quartier du val ebook est
revenu aussi dans l'actualité il ya eu
plusieurs nuits de tension il ya
quelques semaines il y en a de temps en
temps voire quelquefois régulièrement ça
se succèdent quelle réponse vous allez
apporter
il ya une vraie problématique
aujourd'hui est une vraie inquiétude à
la fois dans le quartier du val hibou et
dans les quartiers riverains on
s'aperçoit que des problématiques de
médiation sont en place que des
problématiques de proximité sont en
place aujourd'hui qui ne répondent pas
aux besoins des habitants
on a aussi décrédibilisé le conseil de
quartier du vélib ou en allant contre
les différentes propositions qu'ils ont
fait est là nous nous inscrivons en faux
il y a beaucoup d'initiative des jeunes
des familles qu'il faut aller soutenir
quand vous aviez le millefeuille avec un
certain nombre de salles de réunion qui
était au sein du silo qui n'en finit pas
d'être détruits et qu'on le remplace
toujours par rien derrière pas de salle
de réunion
pas de salle des fêtes qui sont
manquantes pas de salle de famille là il
ya une vraie problématique de mise en
place d'une dynamique pour réunir les
gens pour les leur permettent de prendre
des initiatives en faveur de leur
quartier et surtout ne pas récupérer les
choses pour la photo
de temps en temps mais réellement le
vrai au service des habitants il ya
toute une rénovation qui est menée sur
ce quartier depuis des années ça n'a pas
servi à grand chose c'est ce que vous
nous dites il ya des choses qui sont
oubliés on pourra parler avec le synope
de l'ensemble des canalisations qui date
des années soixante dix et qui tombe
régulièrement en panne et qui ont été
complètement oubliés dans la rénovation
et enfin les dernières annonces qui ont
été faites n'ont rien d'un écoquartier
on est juste en train d'annoncer qu'on
va continuer de bétonner au lieu de
construire des parcs et jardins de
ramener de la nature dans la ville et
surtout de recréer ce tissu associatif
dont on a tous besoin
donc voilà ce sur quoi nous nous allons
nous battre parce que ça manque
cruellement aujourd'hui nous arrivons à
la fin de cet entretien vous aurez bien
évidemment l'occasion de venir débattre
sur ce plateau avec les autres candidats
à cette ville à cette municipalité de de
plaisir un autre même très rapidement
pour terminer
vous habitez plaisir depuis plus de 20
ans professeur à l'université
entrepreneur âgé de 50 ans marié père de
trois enfants votre priorité si vous
êtes élu ce sera cette ville de plaisir
vous allez quitter votre vos activités
au civil non aujourd'hui mes activités
me permette effectivement devrait
correctement de d'optimiser mon agenda
je serai en grosse majorité évidemment
au service de ma ville en priorité et je
n'irai pas cumuler les mandats
et enfin dernière chose j'habite ma
ville et ça fait beaucoup de différence
merci la triage un terreau candidats à
plaisir je rappelle que sur cette
commune la maire sortante joséphine
coleman berger n'a pas encore
officiellement annoncé sa candidature
cela devrait être vraisemblablement le
cas très prochainement cette édition du
7 8 le politique municipale 2020 se
poursuit sur tv 78 chaque mardi en
direct 18h45 nous faisons le point sur
sept sur la campagne des municipales
dans les yvelines avant le premier tour
ce sera le 15 mars direction trappe où
le maire sortant candidat à un nouveau
mandat guy malandain vient de recevoir
le soutien de la république en marge du
malandain aussi un membre du parti
socialiste et qui pour le moment n'a pas
donné suite à nos demandes d'invitation
sur ce plateau pour son adjoint ali
rabais lui aussi candidat mais face à
lui est sous l'étiquette notamment
génération il s'agit là de s'inscrire
dans les traces d'un parti clairement à
droite il estime donc être aujourd'hui
le seul candidat de gauche
pendant ce temps sur cette commune de
trappes othman nasro a présenté une
partie de son programme la tête de liste
engagement trappe citoyen et son
colistier mustapha larfaoui ont dévoilé
10 engagements parmi lesquels l'arrêt de
la bétonisation de la ville isolation
phonique de la nationale 10 une police
municipale 24 heures sur 24 et la baisse
de la taxe foncière
les deux hommes politiques reviennent
sur ce dernier point au micro de michael
elle me donne ce qui est vrai c'est
qu'on a besoin de gens des propriétaires
et de locataires
on a surtout besoin de gens heureux
attrape mais qui peuvent s'engager
au-delà de leurs taxes
la réalité c'est qu'on a un projet qui
va s'adresser à tous les trappistes et
pas une partie de la ville contre une
autre la taxe foncière il faut juste à
positionner intelligemment
quand on parle de l'école c'est
évidemment un sujet et rap est une ville
familiale qui concerne tous les parents
et on retrouve ainsi
encore une fois un projet pour toute la
ville ensemble pour les yvelines le
groupe de la majorité départementale
vient d'attribuer ses premiers soutiens
pour ces municipales 36 ans tous parmi
lesquels philippe benassaya maire
sortant de bois d'arcy jean michel
fourgous maire sortant d'elancourt et
philippe guillen également lui adjoint
aux clayes-sous-bois et puis sonia à
broc maire sortante de saint cyr l'école
pour pierre bédier président des
yvelines il s'agit là je cite de
soutenir ceux qui se distinguent par
leur volonté leur capacité de faire
primer les intérêts locaux de leurs
habitants sur les enjeux politiciens et
qu'ils appartiennent ou non à une
formation politique de droite à poissy
est également le maire sortant karl
olive lui a reçu le soutien de l'épi son
opposante nathalie martin tête de liste
voici demain à dévoile une partie de son
programme et elle met l'accent sur la
cause animale parmi les propositions
qu'elle vient de rendre publique la mise
en place d'une alternative végétarienne
quotidienne dans les cantines scolaires
l'interdiction et le refus de
l'installation de cirques avec animaux
sur la commune ou encore un budget
consacré à la lutte contre la
prolifération des animaux errants et
puis dernières informations avant de
refermer cette édition la candidature
surprise de stéphane mirambeau dans les
colonnes du parisien de ce 25 novembre
le maire sortant annonce briguer un
troisième mandat visé par une plainte
pour harcèlement sexuel lâché par sa
majorité
il avait d'abord annoncé vouloir se
retirer de la vie politique il dit
aujourd'hui elle ne pas vouloir se voir
imposer une mise à l'écart il devra
constituer maintenant une liste complète
pour se présenter devant les électeurs
prochain 7,8 politique mardi prochain en
direct 18h45 je recevrai grégory pop
candidat tête de liste lrm à guyancourt
[Musique]